Taylor Swift fans were ready to come at
Shania Twain after they saw a clip of
Shania talking about Taylor on the AMA
red carpet so someone posted this short
clip of what Shania said to et Taylor is
the epitome of a hard-worker talents
okay so that's all that one fan posted
you
so someone retweeted it saying did this
Nightwing just tonight just call Taylor
Swift ugly yeah yeah yeah good old
Twitter deceiving people again so here's
the full clip of what should I said
about Taylor to et Taylor is the epitome
of a hard-worker talents star but she
carries her beauty with so much grace
and without flaunting and I think she's
just a very special person she's
dedicated serious and you can tell she's
not as twenty trying to get hurt twang
Twain but trying to get her thoughts
together around this subject obviously
so she's stumbling on her words a little
bit but yeah like leave it up to some
fans on Twitter to kind of take on the
right direction
and that's it's so sad too because like
you see how far that that short version
of that reads like I mean it's I think
it's close to like a million views it
has on Twitter already and there are
people that are replying saying no no
here's the full but so you know a bunch
of people are gonna see that even when
you're watching this short clip you
really have to be digging to say that
she's calling somebody ugly
well she's yeah like the beginning of
her sentence this just says yeah you
don't have to be beautiful to be a star
yeah we're just saying I know that's
part of Taylor but Taylor uses that
beauty brother think so yeah like yeah I
think if you clip it like that it does
seem like yeah she's saying you know I
think I think if you're looking for it I
guess but like well yeah that's the
reaction that I was getting online yeah
people were saying ocean is calling
Taylor or at least so yeah it's just
that so yeah not our shares clip so pcs
on that
but that is not what sang they love each
other they did a photo back yes to mine
everybody yeah peace love happiness